welcome EDX is just around the corner
and PDP has developed a fight pad with
NetherRealm Studios Public Mortal Kombat
X 5 pad they're selling one for the Xbox
one and PlayStation 4 and both of those
are backwards compatible with last gen
systems the price is 50 dollars and
that's a lot of money to pay for a
controller that's geared just towards
fighting games now to be honest with you
if yeah it's convenient to have the six
buttons but not necessarily for moral
combat that's a game that uses 8 buttons
so you have to incorporate the shoulder
buttons as well this has those but
honestly it's not that different than if
you're playing with a regular controller
I actually found it easier using the
regular Xbox one and PlayStation 4
controllers that said this will be
useful for other fighting games down the
road such as Street Fighter which is
coming to the PlayStation 4 and you can
use it with full gen systems to play all
the other fighting games that have come
out in the past few years so how does it
perform as a controller in general well
the build quality feels a little cheap
this thing is very very light and you
know the d-pad is pretty comparable if
the Xbox one's d-pad which is not bad
and it works pretty well but it's not
necessarily better than what you're
getting on either console already the
buttons emit a really you know audible
clicking sound it can firmly press
something but they also feel very light
and like hard and plastic if you compare
this to something that you're playing on
the PlayStation 4 with already but the
official sony pad or on the Xbox one
with Microsoft's controller it just
doesn't compare it feels off
so for $50 yeah you're getting a
controller that will work well with a
lot of fighting games and it'll work
with two different consoles but at the
same time do you really need it if
you're playing these fighting games on
current gen systems and you're not gonna
be playing something that requires six
buttons like Street Fighter 4 or 5 well
maybe not when it comes to mobile Kombat
X however the game plays just fine on
the regular controllers so if you're
looking for a controller that's going to
make you better at mobile Kombat X or
make the experience of playing it better
you might not want to drop $50 on this
and just stick to the ones you already
oh
you